the single most remarkable fact of human  existence is how hard it is for human  beings to be happy that sounds extremely  Eastern is this influenced by Eastern  approaches it's absolutely so the other  thing it says is suffering is a basic  characteristic of human life  um and it's absolutely influenced by  Eastern philosophy so it has you know  there are six processes in Act  and again unlike other treatment  approaches it was built from the bottom  up and so there were lots of clinical  science studies being done even before  Act was presented as a treatment model  and so it pulled from things that were  found to be effective and from the  Eastern tradition for example we know  that mindfulness is effective  um and that this basic premise that  suffering is  you know  a part of the human condition